what maybe I'm gay maybe I'm this bigger
than that Chris Martin opening up about
discovering his sexuality but Coldplay
frontman sat down with Rolling Stone
magazine where he opened up about his
teenage years including a time when he
was confused about his sexuality which
he claims made him feel quote homophobic
when I was born in school I walked a bit
funny and I bounced a bit and I was also
very homophobic because I was like if
I'm gay I'm completely by eternity and I
was a kid like just got you know
discovering sexuality like what maybe
I'm gay maybe I'm this man that Martin
recalled enduring harsh comments from
classmates on top of his internal
struggles the singer says this went on
for a few years before one day he seemed
to be at peace with everything about
fifteen and a half I don't know what
happened but I was like yes so whoa and
then it all just stopped overnight it
was very interesting and having a bit
more exposure to the world thinking abut
but a lot of my heroes are gay or
whatever whatever they are doesn't
doesn't really matter
following the stars high-profile
marriage and divorce from Guana Paltrow
he has now found love in actress Dakota
Johnson the pair was spotted on a date
night this past September just a couple
months after the two were seen on the
beach with Paltrow and her husband Brad
Falchuk
[Music]